ja willkommen zu aktuellen Sitzung heute
geht es um das Thema globale
Gerechtigkeit
globale Gerechtigkeit unterscheidet sich
noch weiter in konkrete Formen nämlich
in Verteilungsgerechtigkeit und in
Klimagerechtigkeit und ich möchte heute
zu beiden etwas sagen mich aber vor
allem auf Klimagerechtigkeit
konzentrieren zunächst zum Thema
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit hier sehen wir
das hier einige Punkte berücksichtigt
werden können zum einen Gesundheit
Gesundheit sollte möglichst gleich
verteilt werden nicht nur einzelne
Staaten sondern auf der gesamten Welt
natürlich gehört dazu auch
Gesundheitsvorsorge aber auch Medizin
ein weiteres Thema ist Bildung und man
sieht Bildung hängt häufig auch stark
mit Gesundheit zusammen also Menschen
die einen höheren
Bildungsgrad Bildungsstand haben sie
leben in der Regel auch gesünder
Nahrung hängt damit natürlich auch
zusammen
gute gesunde Nahrung macht Menschen
gesünder schlechte Nahrung entsprechend
weniger gesünder oder kranke und jetzt
kann man sich noch fragen ob auch das
Internet eine Form von
gut ist das gleiche Maßen auf der Welt
verteilt werden sollte es spricht hier
einiges dafür dass Internet ist ein
Medium was uns ganz viele andere Dinge
erlaubt zu realisieren wie zum Beispiel
Gesundheit wir können durch das Medium
Internet Informationen bekommen über
Gesundheit also auch Diagnostik aber
auch Ratschläge und sonstiges wissen
natürlich auch die Bildung das heißt wir
können durch das Internet auch immer
mehr partizipieren an Bildungsinhalten
und zwar unabhängig von unserem Standort
auch unabhängig von unserer möglichen
körperlichen Einschränkung das heißt
Barrierefreiheit und Partizipation ist
hier global möglich durch das Internet
das worldwide web das weltweite Netz ist
ein Paradebeispiel dafür wie globale
Gerechtigkeit realisiert werden kann
natürlich haben lange noch nicht alle
Menschen auf der Welt
dieser Zugang teilweise weil es keine
internetabdeckung gibt teilweise bei
mobile Endgeräte fehlt teilweise aber
auch weil der Zugang zum Internet aus
politischen Gründen erschwert wird und
vielleicht auch nur manche Seiten manche
Inhalte des Internets erlaubt werden und
manch hingegen verboten werden oder ein
mögt ein Zugriff gar nicht möglich ist
das ist also eine spannende Frage und
meine These wäre das Internet ist ein
Kandidat zu einem Art von Grundrecht zu
werden also Internet Zugang könnte in
der Zukunft genauso auch wie Zugang zu
Strom Wasser Gesundheit Bildung zu einer
Art von Grundrecht werden das muss man
zumindest noch diskutieren jetzt möchte
ich aber zum nächsten Thema kommen was
mindestens genauso aktuell ist nämlich
die Klimagerechtigkeit die auch als eine
Form von globaler Gerechtigkeit gelten
kann weil sie eben die gesamte Welt
betrifft das Klima ist ein Phänomen was
nicht
nur bezogen auf manche Staaten oder
Gesellschaften Geltung hat sondern es
ist über national es ist ein globales
Phänomen ist betrifft die gesamte Welt
und dazu möchte ich zunächst ein Exkurs
geben zur Geschichte der Umweltbewegung
Umweltbewegung klimabewusstsein
klimagerechtigkeitsbewusstsein ist noch
ein recht neues Phänomen es beginnt im
Ausgang der
späten 60er Jahre vor allem in den 70er
Jahren und dann aber auch durch den
Kalten Krieg in den 80er Jahren dieses
Bild aus Wikipedia ist daraus dann
dieses Logo atomkraft nein danke wurde
in dieser Zeit geprägt dann hier dann
sieht man Greta Thunberg der Schulstreik
das heißt diese dieses Klima Bewusstsein
betrifft nach und nach auch die jüngere
Generation nicht nur die
mittelalterliche Generation wie auf dem
Bild aus den 80er Jahren als betrifft
die gesamte Gesellschaft sie wird
dadurch sen realisiert auch mobilisiert
sie wird teilweise eben auch
radikalisiert das sieht man an der
letzten Generation und neuerdings wird
eben auch diskutiert ob es sich dabei um
eine kriminelle Vereinigung handelt
darüber wollen wir hier nicht
diskutieren ich möchte das nur zu
bedenken geben wie eben auch das
Bewusstsein um globale Gerechtigkeit
sich in Klima Demonstrationen zeigt wie
hier etwa ölsprache statt bohren ein
sogenannter Klima Kleber der hier vom
Boden gelöst werden muss aber man sieht
ja auch es findet eine Radikalisierung
statt die sogar auch in den öffentlichen
Raum der Museen eindringt hier sieht man
einen Farbanschlag auf ein Gemälde was
natürlich zur Demonstration dieses
Anliegens gelten soll hier auf Sylt
wurde ein Privatflugzeug mit Farbe
attackiert was natürlich auch die
Aussage beinhaltet
Klima Gerechtigkeit oder Klima
Ungerechtigkeit wird gerade dadurch
hergestellt dass manche Menschen sich es
leisten mit einem solchen Flugzeug zu
fliegen und dementsprechend sehr viel
CO2 auszustoßen man hat berechnet der
CO2-Ausstoß für einen Passagier auf der
Strecke von München nach New York
beträgt 800 Kilogramm CO2 das ist also
doch ziemlich viel und diese
CO2-Gase sind eben auch
verantwortlich so zumindest die Mehrheit
der Forschung für den Klimawandel also
auch für die Erwärmung und die
Überschwemmung damit einhergehen hier
sieht man noch eine Demonstration dieser
Klima Gegner auf einem Golfplatz gegen
den Wasserverbrauch die eben auch zur zu
Begrünung hier dieses Platzes genutzt
wird und hier Pflanzen sie einem nur ein
Bäumchen auf auf diesem Rasen auf dem
normalerweise Golf gespielt wird ja was
ist jetzt überhaupt klimaethik müssen
uns sagen hier gibt es von Dieter
Birnbacher ein sehr kommentierte
Einführung die klimaethik und er spricht
hier davon dass man unterscheiden muss
zwischen Umweltbelastungen das sind also
folgen die uns direkt betreffen also
diejenigen Firmen Personen
starten die diese
Schadstoffe
produzieren werden im Sinne der
Umweltbelastung direkt unmittelbar
betroffen zum Beispiel auch durch
Lärmbelastung aber auch sonstige Dinge
wie
umweltverschmutzende
Abgase die uns direkt zum Beispiel durch
Atemnot betreffen davon unterscheidet
jetzt Birnbacher noch Klimaprobleme die
sind wir seit von anderer Art als die
Umweltbelastung weil sie uns nicht
direkt betreffen die wir sie erzeugen
sondern weil sie sich auch zeitlich
verzögert bemerkbar machen also hier ist
das Thema Generation Gerechtigkeit
angesprochen sie können auch erst
künftige Generation treffen und uns
nicht unmittelbar und sie sind auch
häufig nicht mehr umkehrbar sie
betreffen zum Beispiel die Ozonschicht
das Ozonloch ist ein Beispiel von einem
Klima Problem es ist ja auch viel später
entstanden nachdem man schon lange Jahre
diese fckwstoffe in die Atmosphäre
entlassen hat und das ist ein wichtiger
Punkt aber es ist auch noch anderes
wichtig nämlich dass sich Klima Probleme
nicht auf bestimmte Länder oder Region
begrenzen lassen
sondern dass sie asymmetrisch wie er
sagt hier sich vollziehen das heißt die
Menschen Industrien gesellschaftlichen
Staaten die diese
Klimaprobleme erzeugen zum Beispiel
durch Emissionen die leiden da gar nicht
darunter unter Umständen zum ist leiden
andere Region der Welt darunter durch
Dürre durch Überschwemmungen und so
weiter das ist als ein asymmetrischen
Ungleichgewicht und das führt natürlich
direkt auch zur Frage nach der
Gerechtigkeit der globalen Gerechtigkeit
oder auch der Klimagerechtigkeit und es
gibt jetzt hier verschiedene
Möglichkeiten wie man diese
Klimagerechtigkeit herstellen kann er
spricht jetzt hier von der
Absenkung der Emissionen das ist die
mittigeration und von dem Ausgleich der
bewirten Schäden die Kompensation die
Kompensation das ist sicherlich eine der
wichtigsten Punkte für die
Klimagerechtigkeit das bedeutet Staaten
Firmen die verantwortlich sind für
asymmetrische
Klimaschäden sollten auch die
betroffenen Menschen oder Regionen
kompensieren durch zum Beispiel
finanzielle Zahlung man sieht das auch
neuerdings
anhand von
Zahlungen die man leisten kann beim
Fliegen durch CO2
kompensationsgebühren natürlich ist es
immer noch eine freiwillige Leistung die
nicht alle Menschen gerne
bezahlen aber das ist zumindest ein
Zeichen dafür dass einzelne
Industriezweige dieses Problem der
Klimagerechtigkeit bereits erkannt haben
ja dann bedanke ich mich für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten Sitzung